- [Interviewer] So, the first
one is, um, this is from--
- [Director] Wait, can
I just have a quick,
one of you just do a quick clap for me.
(Tan and Bobby clap)
Great.
- [Interviewer] Wicked.
(bubbly orchestral music)
I have found Queer Eye to be one
of my favorite shows of the year.
It's got such a fantastic feel for outta.
I think the guys really care about
the people who they are transforming.
But it opens up such an
interesting discussion
about mental health, about
looking after yourself,
self-care, and relationships.
So, to celebrate the second season,
we were asked if we wanted
to interview the guys.
Essentially like, the week leading up
to the interview was not
that great, personally.
It was just really hard to
kind of, get through it.
Like, I'm such a big fan of the show,
and I was really trying to be
pumped up for the interview,
but I was feeling very, very anxious
about meeting them, and like,
screwing it up, essentially.
We've got one from Matthew, who says,
this is more interior design level,
say, "I'm a huge Star
Wars fan, and right now,
"my room, my apartment looks
more like a 14 year old's
"boy's room, rather than
an adult apartment."
So it started off pretty well.
The guys were really nice, but I thought,
"Okay, just power through these questions.
"Power through these questions."
And then we got to the bit that
I was asking Karamo about self-care
and helping yourself,
and he was coming back
with some really meaningful advice
that actually related incredibly much
to my own personal situation I'd been
going through for the previous few weeks.
And it really overly resonated with me.
So then, I was like, "Oh, that
was a really good answer."
- And if you get a no today, it doesn't
mean you'll get a no tomorrow.
- I'm keeping a note of that. (laughs)
It happened again later on.
There was a question about relationships.
This one is quite sad, but hopefully,
we can find some good things.
It says, "How do you move on from someone
"you love, who doesn't love you back?"
- Ooh.
- There was another
fantastic set of points made,
and it felt really
personal, even though it was
actually somebody else's problem.
Then, I was like, oh my God, this is just
so deeply personal.
That is another one I'm
going to be writing down.
(they laugh)
'Cause it's just, you
know, it's just (groans).
But then, I inadvertently
blurted out something like,
"I'm having a shit month."
These questions aren't
from me, by the way.
(they laugh)
- You really are going
through it, aren't you?
- [Scott] Yeah, I'm having
a really shit month.
- [Bobby And Tan] Awww!
- No, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not.
No, no, no, it's fine.
At the end of the interview,
just when we were wrapping up,
they're all getting up,
and about to go, Karamo
then came over and was
like, "Are you okay?"
And I was like, "I'm fine."
You know, I thought I was okay.
And then, out of nowhere,
they all initiated a hug,
and they all kind of went in.
(group cheers around him)
And my God, it was like,
the most unexpected
flow of emotion I've
had in such a long time,
and I was a bit beside myself.
And I didn't kind of know what to do.
It was, I mean, it smelled brilliant.
It was fantastic, but I was a
bit of a mess, to be honest.
What Queer Eye is so
fantastic at is kind of,
opening that discussion
about mental health,
about being you know, caring
for people around you.
And the fact that it's
okay not to be okay.
And I think for me, that was just,
had such a resonance, that I
just didn't necessarily expect.
And I think that's
just was really quite powerful to me.
(soft contemporary music)